it's one of the biggest lockdowns china
has imposed during the pandemic one that
looks a lot like what happened in wuhan
two years ago when kovin 19 first
emerged
since late december 13 million people in
the city of xi'an have been ordered to
stay home as the delta variant led to an
outbreak of more than 2 000 cases a high
number for china they're not letting
people in or out of the city really
taking
just a very very aggressive approach
china has locked down a number of cities
during the pandemic and in early january
reported its first case of the
fast-spreading omicron variant in the
city of tianjin
but this time what's happening in xi'an
has sparked a nationwide outcry online
about food shortages
some stranded residents said on social
media that they were down to their last
pack of instant noodles
but the government says there are enough
food supplies
and the lockdown in xi'an could also
threaten the global semiconductor
shortage especially since the city is
home to some of the world's biggest
memory chip makers
the stakes are high as china is about to
host the winter olympics and the
lockdown in xi'an is turning out to be a
big test for china's zero kovid strategy
so how strict is the lockdown in xi'an
when the rules first came into effect
one person per household was allowed to
go out once every two days to buy food
and other necessities but restrictions
were tightened after a few days with
tens of thousands sent to quarantine
centers and everyone else banned from
leaving their homes except to get a
covet test similar to the rules in wuhan
back in 2020 certainly a lot of people
are making the comparison between wuhan
and xi'an and we've seen as in wuhan two
years ago we see stories coming out
through
social media primarily of
families households people encountering
pretty difficult circumstances
the government promised free delivery of
groceries to those stranded at home but
many complained online saying they
received little to no supplies
the hashtag xion grocery shopping is
difficult was viewed more than 400
million times on the chinese social
media platform weibo as of january 7th
and some say the government hasn't
provided enough food since the lockdown
began
[Music]
there were also complaints about run-ins
with authorities enforcing the rules
this video which has been widely shared
since new year's eve shows a man being
beaten by guards with comments saying
that he had gone out to buy steamed buns
the owner of the video couldn't be
reached and it hasn't been independently
verified the police acknowledged the
incident and said the two guards had
been punished with a seven day detention
and a thirty dollar fine
hospitals have been also widely
criticized on social media for not
giving medical care to some patients
with non-covet conditions for instance a
pregnant woman said she was denied
medical attention because of an expired
kova test authorities later said they
would loosen some requirements but then
they're definitely people who both
within xi'an and outside of xi'an are
supportive of these measures people who
look at the chinese government response
and say that was the right thing to do
the lockdown in xi'an could also
exacerbate the global shortage of
semiconductors found in the electronics
we use every day
samsung and micron are some of the
world's largest chip makers and both
have factories in xi'an according to
research firm trend force samsung has
two production lines in the city that
make flash memory products used in
devices such as hard drives and cameras
samsung didn't give details but said it
had to temporarily adjust operations
mikron said the city's closure had some
impact on its output of chips but it was
working with officials to identify
solutions if they need to make an
adjustment to their xi'an operations
that may mean that affects
some of their other chip operations
elsewhere we'll have to see how big of a
hit this will be
just weeks before china is set to host
the winter olympics in beijing health
authorities confirmed the first cases of
omicron in the neighboring city of
tianjin and they ordered mass testing
for its 14 million residents you have
officials everywhere who are looking at
xi'an's example and who are going to be
hoping that they are not subjected to
the same sort of scrutiny
the winter olympics is set to begin on
february 4th and china is allowing
foreigners to enter in large numbers for
the first time since the pandemic began
though under very strict rules to
minimize contact with locals
with cold temperatures increasing
transmissibility and countries around
the world reporting hundreds of
thousands of daily cases keeping out
coven 19 is becoming more challenging
china already is feeling a lot of
pressure to really pull off these
olympics and make them succeed there's
obviously also a lot of geopolitical
pressure on china right now and so i
think the best answer that they want to
have is to say we pulled off a
successful olympics and part of that
includes containing coping
you